Now that we have a file path where we
can save our GIF's we just need to add
two method calls.
The method that saves the GIF's,
archiveRootObject,
and the method that retrieves them,
unarchiveObjectWithFile.
If you look in the app delegate
of the Objective C project
you'll see that these two
methods are called here.
But we want to keep our
swift app delicate nice and
clean, so we're going to call these
methods, in the save to GIF's
view controller instead, so
switching back to our swift project.
So here we are in our save to
GIF's view controller, and
I'm going to suggest that we
call archive root object,
as soon as a GIF is saved, here in
the method previewVC, didSaveGif.
Now where should we put the method
call that retrieves our GIF's.